[Musique]
certains d'entre vous me connaissez
peut-être et d'autres peut-être pas
pourtant je suis sûr que en me voyant
arriver sur scène vous vous êtes déjà
fait une petite idée de qui je suis basé
sur mon apparence c'est tout à fait
normal c'est un automatisme l'humain
étant un être social
il engage un processus de comparaison et
puis de catégorisation pour mieux
interpréter et comprendre les nouvelles
choses qu'ils rencontrent
c'est le fait de prendre un nouvel
élément de le comparer à ce qu'on
connaît déjà de voir à quoi il
correspond le plus et puis de le mettre
dans la même catégorie
j'aimerais prendre quelqu'un dans
l'audience et vous montrez ce processus
devant par exemple vous je ne vous
connais absolument pas et pourtant basée
sur ce que je vois de vous et les
stéréotypes qui monte en tête quand je
vous regarde je peux définir quelques
faits à propos de vous donc vous êtes
une fille vous êtes en secondaire et je
me dirais que dans vos passe temps vous
faites parce que vous êtes une fille de
la danse vous êtes intéressé par la
danse de près ou de loin
vous devez sûrement avoir un côté
créatif et vous devez sûrement écouter
de la pop dans vos genres musicaux ce
qui m'intéresse ce n'est pas le fait que
ce soit juste
c'est juste que ces catégorisations
m'aide à mettre une étiquette dans ma
tête sur vous en 10 ans filles plus ou
moins dans la norme
même si il faut garder en tête que ces
catégorisations ne s'applique pas à tout
le monde dans une même communauté
il ya toujours une généralisation et
c'est ce qu'on utilise absolument tout
le temps voilà pourquoi parfois ces
stéréotypes sont vraies il y a tout
d'abord le fait que ont grandi dans un
cercle familial et un cercle d'amis
assez restreint à l'école par exemple
même s'il ya beaucoup de com de
nationalités différentes
c'est nationalité reste tout européenne
et peu de personnes sont des rides sont
d'origine externe à l'europe
avec le temps les ressemblances entre
les personnes d'une même communauté se
renforce
ce qui fait que les fossés entre
différentes communautés augmente aussi
si vous regardez votre voisin vous ne
vous rendrez pas compte directement que
cette personne vous ressemble
tout simplement parce que vous la
connaissez ou bien vous la voyez
régulièrement
maintenant si vous vous comparez avec
quelqu'un habitant loin dans un autre
pays vous rendrez compte que du aux lois
et aux cultures qui change cette
personne à des normes très différentes
des nôtres
un autre des facteurs c'est que la
société est construite autour de ça les
passe-temps des enfants influent les
passe temps ils sont souvent influencés
par la société que ce soit leur état
d'esprit leur sport qui font ou même
peut-être le métier qu'ils feront plus
tard quand on rentre dans un magasin de
jouets il ya toujours le rayon fille et
le rayon garçons et les magasins se
sentent obligés d'écrire filles et
garçons comme si on pouvait pas faire ce
qu'on veut il ya un rayon rose et un
rayon bleu un rayon ou les jeux c'est
d'apprendre à être maman en s'exerçant
sur les poupées et un rayon où on
apprend à être ambitieux et fort un
rayon où il faut être belle et neigeuses
et un rayon où on fait travailler nos
méninges
on s'intéresse aux sciences et on prouve
qu'on est courageux
ne pensez-vous pas qu'il faudrait revoir
le message qu'on envoie aux nouvelles
générations
car les arrangements de la société on
peut être l'air banal mais il modélise
en réalité énormément nos état d'esprit
faire comme maman et faire tout comme
papa je ne crois pas que ce soit la
meilleure des idées ça voudrait dire
imiter la société actuelle une société
qui est patriarcale ça voudrait dire
aussi que l'image qu'on a c'est la femme
et l'homme sans intermédiaire comme si
c'étaient deux extrêmes les conséquences
sont que la femme ne cherchant qu'à être
belle ne va va pouvoir va subir une
baisse en compte de confiance en soi et
l'homme ne va pas s'autoriser
à être de temps à autres faible parce
qu'il va avoir peur de ne pas être
inclus dans une communauté
on ne laisse pas le choix aux gens en
général on offre aussi des bijoux et des
et du maquillage sans se demander si
elles veulent être à ce point féminine
et aux garçons on leur ordonne tête fort
physiquement et émotionnellement sans
leur lécher sans leur laisser le choix
de leur personnalité
les films eux aussi renforcés
stéréotypes
ils se servent des stéréotypes pour
qu'on s'identifie au personnage et pour
créer une caricature les clichés qu'on
peut souvent retrouvé c'est le cancre
qui trichent et qui est bien évidemment
il est la première de la classe qui est
bien évidemment à elles de manière plus
générale les films américains qui sont
typiquement destiné aux adolescents
utilisent ces stéréotypes
il ya toujours le groupe découler des
pas cool dans les cool les filles et les
garçons c'est les garçons qui sont dans
l'équipe de sport de les rliss de leur
lycée qui sont très sportif mais nul à
l'école et les filles qui ne font que se
maquiller et potiner après dans le
groupe d pas cool on leur a donné
le packaging complet de l'intello les
lunettes
l'appareil dentaire et les vêtements
excentriques vu comme ça ce type de film
ne fait de mal à personne
ce n'est pas si grave vu qu'on ne relie
pas directement
l'histoire du film avec notre vie
personnelle mais le problème c'est qu'un
jeune garçon qui ne ressemble pas à
l'acteur principal parce qu'il n'est pas
assez sportif et une fille qui n'est pas
assez studieuse
que pensez vous qu'ils vont comprendre
comme message voilà pourquoi étant noyés
de tous les côtés par ses idéaux
préconçues il est très dure voire
impossible de s'en défaire c'est dommage
car en allant dans cette direction on
perd toute la richesse de la communauté
qui est la diversité sur une note plus
joyeuse
il ya quand même des personnes qui
souhaitent changer ça des personnes font
des films qui
font en sorte de bousculer les
mentalités comme le fait le film green
book
ce film met en avant deux personnes un
italo-américain et un afro-américain et
globalement le film traite des clichés
qu'on attribue au noir et au blanc alors
les clichés qu'on attribue aux blancs la
plupart du temps c'est le snobisme
l'alcool le raffinement et les clichés
qu'on attribue au noir le plus rare de
manière plus générale c'est le vol le
poulet et qu'ils écoutent évidemment la
musique de leur communauté
sauf que le réalisateur ne s'est pas
arrêté là ça aurait été trop banal de
suivre ces stéréotypes
il a donc interchanger les clichés qu'on
attribue généralement aux blancs en les
donnant à l'afro américain et les
clichés qu'on attribue généralement au
noir à l'italo américain je trouve que
ça a été fait subtilement jeudi
subtilement parce que avant de l'avoir
étudiée en cours d'anglais je ne m'étais
pas rendu compte que ces clichés ne
correspondait pas à l'apparence de la
personne ce qui m'a à moi prouver que
ces stéréotypes sont très clairement
subjectif et interchangeables donc même
si certaines séries dénonce l'homophobie
le racisme la xénophobie et bien plus de
choses
il y a encore du chemin à faire il ya
encore du chemin à faire pour que tout
le monde comprenne réellement
l'importance de ce combat
ce qui va être très dur car on a
énormément intériorisé ses
caractéristiques et ses stéréotypes
je vais vous raconter comment je m'en
suis aperçu vous avez sûrement tous
entendu parler de la série netflix sex
education
c'est une série qui raconte la vie
d'adolescent et je me suis intéressé aux
acteurs de aux acteurs de cette série
dont j'ai regardé une vidéo qui
racontait les acteurs et puis les
personnages de la série le moment où le
personnage eric a été présenté un
personnage donc le personnage est
d'origine nigérienne qui est homosexuel
et qui a une famille croyante
le présentateur a dit à quel point la
série était positif
parce qu'elle est forte elle demandé aux
gens d'accepter l'homosexualité et
voulait rendre ça tout à fait banal je
suis tout à fait d'accord
la série prend des gens et montre que
même s'ils sont décalés par rapport aux
normes de la société
ils ne sont pas moins épanouie dans la
suite de la vidéo
le présentateur parle de l'acteur en
lui-même en décrivant sa carrière et ses
passions il dit qu'il est très
charismatique et ajoute que l'audience
féminine gardera un oeil sur les
relations amoureuses de l'acteur
l'audience féminine
alors oui peut-être que l'audience
féminine sera intéressé mais pourquoi
pas l'audience masculine ce qui m'a
choqué dans cette vidéo c'est que le
présentateur vient de dire à quel point
l'homosexualité devrait être acceptée et
lui même par ses choix de mots ne
l'acceptent pas c'est pour ça que par la
manière dont on agit et dont on parle
on peut exclure ou inclure des millions
de gens premièrement ça empêche les gens
de librement évoluer à travers les idées
préconçues de la société et ses idées se
transmettent de génération en génération
c'est trop rigide ensuite ce qu'il m'a
fait penser à la phrase qu'on dit
souvent pour arranger les choses
fous toi du regard des autres
cette fois j'en suis sûr et rempli de
boue une conviction mais ça n'arrange
rien du tout je pense que ça ne suffit
pas je pense que ce ne soit pas aux gens
exclu de faire un effort pour être
inclus je pense que c'est à la société
entière de faire un effort pour inclure
les gens ce que j'aimerais que vous
retenez de mon speech c'est qu'il existe
un grand spectre de possibilités et que
avant de rencontrer une personne vous ne
pouvez pas déterminer où se place la
personne par rapport à ce spectre même
les gens que vous connaissez
il ne faut pas se dire qu'elle ne peut
pas évolué par rapport à ce spectre
ne vous arrêtez donc pas à la première
impression d'une personne laissez les
gens changer votre opinion laissez les
vous à vous surprendre
merci
[Applaudissements]